laughs
[Laughter]
you're gonna get it
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my video for the joker
deleted scene an alternate ending and
obviously a lot of questions about
what's going on with the joker as a
character during the new batman movies
that are being made with robert
pattinson and matt reeves there's a
whole bunch of easter eggs so if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get everything we'll actually do a
giveaway for the joker movie on blu-ray
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the movie on the video
so we'll start by talking about the
joker alternate ending and deleted scene
then i'll talk about the batman movie
and what's going on with the joker
character during the new trilogy
the deleted scene is a big change to the
ending and a big change to the version
of the batman mythos that we got during
the movie because the one that we got
even though there are a couple minor
changes is pretty close to a comic book
accurate version of his origin story
they just kind of leave it at that
moment with him in the alley way
but in that version one of the writing
men in the clown masks here's joker's
broadcast from murray's studio isn't
inspired by his words and he just
happens to be standing outside the movie
theater that thomas martha and bruce
wayne just exited
follows them into the alleyway and gives
us our expectedly mostly comic book
accurate version of a batman origin
story where he guns down
thomas and martha wayne ripping off the
pearls which is also right off the comic
book page
and leaving bruce sitting there in shock
with their bodies around him
you also probably noticed a bunch of
batman easter eggs as they're exiting
the theater too
meta easter eggs for the joker character
as well because this is meant to be
early 80s era gotham and they actually
dated because of the movies that are
being released as you see on the walls
and the posters
excalibur is just a really awesome old
school king arthur movie if you've never
seen it i would recommend it
zorro the gay blade is just a comedy
version of the classic zorro story
and then the comedy film arthur all
three of those were released in 1981 so
you say the joker movie happened in 1981
the one minor change that they made to
the classic comic book batman origin
story is the actual movie that they were
seeing at the theater before they were
gunned down
in the original version of the origin
story it was the 1940
mark of zorro movie because adult batman
was created in the comics in 1939 so
that just happened to be the most recent
version of zorro that was released
publicly
they just changed that to this version
of zorro to be period specific to 1981.
i also kind of feel like they included
the arthur comedy movie because it would
have been playing around this time and
his name is arthur fleck during the
movie
the alternate version of this ending
would have been dramatically different
in a much bigger change to the batman
origin story
in the deleted scene when joker is in
the white clothes at arkham asylum
talking to his therapist and starts
laughing saying i was thinking of a joke
you wouldn't understand it we would have
flashed back to the same scene of thomas
and martha wayne dying but instead of
joe chill
being the one in the clown mask to kill
them it would have been joker himself
killing the wanes then as he turns to
walk away bruce wayne starts crying out
in shock
joker pauses the beat shrugs turns
around
kills bruce wayne too then walks away it
would have definitively
answered what their take on the batman
character was like no there's not gonna
be a batman in this universe
obviously because that scene didn't make
it into the final cut of the movie it's
not canon anymore and you could still
assume that someday there will be a
batman running around this version of
gotham
but you probably understand why they
chose to get rid of that scene it sounds
horrifying and just in favor of
something a little more toned down a
little more comic book accurate
and way more ambiguous just to give the
audience a chance to take their own
interpretation
if you were confused about what was
going on at the end of the movie and
what this symbolism meant with him
walking down the hallway
so the scene of joker talking to the
therapist was supposed to be happening
after a short time jump where he was
eventually captured by the police
brought to arkham asylum
and this person is just evaluating his
mental state the very end seen with the
junk cut to him walking down the hallway
as the music's playing
leaving the footprints is meant to imply
that he killed the therapist
is in the process of escaping arkham
asylum and will go on to become the
comic book joker
yes since the movie has won all those
awards joaquin phoenix just won best
actor for oscar
well deserved congratulations to him he
had a great speech there has been real
talk of them doing a joker sequel
eventually but there's been no talk of
what that would be
what time period it would take place
during i'll do more videos for it if
they make some more official
announcements
if they really are gonna do a sequel i
think one of the best characters they
could go for
if they want to do something in the dc
black label universe that's not
connected to any of the other batman or
justice league films the riddler would
be a great character to do a spin like
you did on the joker with joaquin
phoenix
tom king just did a big story about the
war of jokes and riddles it was all
about them battling the riddler and the
joker over who got the honor of killing
batman it was funny how they almost
didn't even care about batman while this
was going on they were so fixated on
each other so it was really like this
big turf war that they had
which i think you could totally do on
the lesser scale that these dc black
labels seem to be like them spending
less than 100 million dollars to make it
r-rated
but because they just released that new
batman teaser with the first look at
robert pattinson's batman in the new bat
suit
everyone is wondering what are they
going to do with his most iconic villain
in the new batman trilogy i've seen a
lot of you also asking would joaquin
phoenix the joker ever cross over with
the new batman movies if the timeline
makes
sense well when they were making the
joker movie todd phillips was hyping up
his dc black label like this is meant to
be separate i'm doing my own thing i
don't want to have to pay attention to
what those other people are doing with
the other dc and justice league
characters
doing it that way is also part of how he
sold them on doing a rated r version of
the character
because you couldn't really do a rated r
joker trying to cross it over with the
pg-13 movies you would have to tone it
way way down
when people specifically asked todd
phillips about crossing over with the
robber patents in batman movies
he said definitely not at least right
now but when you think of this from matt
reeve's perspective because he's making
a batman movie so he has
control of pretty much any character
that he wants to use from batman's
rogues gallery
right now joker is confirmed to not be
in the new batman movie that they're
filming
right now as we speak but eventually
they're going to make their way through
all of batman's biggest most
iconic rogues gallery of villains
through the other films in the trilogy
you can still get away with not doing
joker in the second movie in the next
two to three years because you still
have a ton of awesome classic villains
that aren't going to be in the first
movie
like clay face mr freeze two-face so
early prediction
matt reeves doesn't try to use a version
of the joker until the third
robert pattinson batman movie assuming
that they do get through a new trilogy
and everything goes well
that would be minimum five to six years
before that could even happen
so by that time they'll be fine to
recast a new version of the joker
character if they want
to exist within the continuity of those
new batman movies so as of right now i
don't think there's any plans to cross
over
joaquin phoenix's joker with any of the
other dc movies if he does joke or two
it'll be its own thing off by itself
that's kind of the way they're pitching
the new batman movies is they take place
often their own little bubble of
continuity because it's set during a
different time period
so he hasn't met aquaman yet he hasn't
met wonder woman superman any of those
other characters so you don't really
have to worry about him crossing over
with the other justice league films
anytime soon i realize dc's continuity
sounds like it's kind of a mess right
now because
birds of prey is connected to the first
suicide squad film
but james gunn is getting ready to
release a new suicide squad movie which
is kind of a reboot of the franchise
then you have the aquaman sequel which
is still technically connected to
justice league you have wonder woman
1984 which is set during the past
so don't worry about it too much right
now just on a case-by-case movie by
movie basis i will explain the timeline
and what's connected what's not
connected
they actually just dropped a bunch of
new previews for wonder woman 1984
and it seems like we got our first look
for what cheetah actually looks like
during that movie so i might do a
breakdown of that sometime soon
but everyone let me know in the comments
what do you want them to do with the
joker character
in the new robert patins and batman
movies do you want them to recast
a different version of the character or
do you hope that they just skip the
joker all together and they never do him
again
inside the robber patins and movies
everyone click here to re-watch that new
batman teaser trailer
and click here for my brand new avengers
infinity saga deleted scene
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome this is the way